make the most important thing the most
important thing what's great about that
is that can mean whatever you want it to
mean and that definition can change with
the various seasons of Life absolutely
and for me it even changes throughout a
year of course my family is like always
my priority but when I'm getting ready
for a race like the World Championships
I go all in and I'm not as present of a
parent as I am during other seasons of
the year and I go to training camp
without my daughter and I really like
focus in on this one thing that I want
to achieve when the race is over like
I'm a full-time mom for a while and my
focus is back on my families I think
it's important to for us like as busy as
we all are to like give ourselves
permission to go all in on the things
that matter to us and and to not feel so
much guil and to be okay with those
choices